after 10 months together a source  confirms two people that Selena on the  weekend are calling it quits distance  reportedly played a big factor in the  split with the weekend on tour in Salina  filming in New York since then she's  been hanging out with her acts Justin  Bieber a lot can't keep my hands to  myself the pair spent all day yesterday  together first going to breakfast and  then to church but they've reportedly  been on better terms ever since Selena's  kidney transplant and have met up more  than once but a source tells people the  pair are still not back together as for  the weekend eagle-eyed fans have noticed  that he's unfollowed some of Selena's  closest friends and family on Instagram  including her mother and even her organ  donor francia raisa